ich begrüße jetzt bei bild live im
studio friedrich merz oppositionsführer
im deutschen bundestag und
parteivorsitzende der cdu herr merz ich
fragte ganz direkt haben wir uns von
putin ein dulden lassen
wo ihr das ist ein schwarzer tag für die
welt und wir alle haben seine rhetorik
nicht richtig eingeschätzt wir haben ihm
streckenweise sogar geglaubt und das hat
sich heute spätestens mit diesem
ereignissen in der ukraine als eine
täuschung erwiesen und jetzt sind wir
auf dem boden der realität hart
aufgeschlagen
wenn wir ihm fälschlicherweise geglaubt
haben und er hat immer wieder gelogen
immer aufs neue ist immer einen schritt
weiter gegangen dann wissen wir dass der
zeitpunkt erreicht ist wirklich eine
grenze zu ziehen und zu sagen ab jetzt
ist das vertrauen vollkommen verspielt
und welche konsequenzen würden dann wenn
wir die linie nun erkennen daraus
erwachsen na ja spätestens in der nacht
von gestern auf heute ist dieser punkt
erreicht
putin führt krieg und zwar nicht allein
gegen die ukraine das ist für sich
genommen schlimm genug er führt krieg
gegen die gesamte demokratische welt und
das ist ja auch sein gegner es ist nicht
die nato putin weiß dass die nato ihnen
nicht bedroht die nato bedroht niemanden
hat noch niemanden bedroht bedroht auch
russland nicht hat russland nie bedroht
putin weiß dass putin fühlt sich
wahrscheinlich zu recht bedroht von
allen freiheitsbewegungen er fühlt sich
bedroht von demokratie in seiner
nachbarschaft und das war der grund
warum er georgien in gleicher weise
behandelt hat das war der grund warum er
angst bekommen hat als die
freiheitsbewegung gegen die gefälschten
wahlen in belarus aufgestanden ist und
wenn sie es einmal auch im zeitablauf
der letzten sagen wir zwei jahre sehen
dann ist die radikalisierung erst seiner
rhetorik und jetzt seines
militärapparates eingetreten mit diesen
ereignissen in minsk
das ist das eigentliche problem dass er
sieht und diese bedrohung seines systems
die ist real glauben sie dass putin
letzten endes danach strebt wieder eine
art sowjetunion aufzubauen begriff auch
die historische konnotation als solche
ist mehrfach vorgekommen in der großen
rede die er vor zwei tagen abends
gehalten ja und das war nicht die erste
rede die in diese richtung ging putin
hat mehrfach in den reden der letzten
jahre immer wieder bedauert dass das
größte
problem aus seiner sicht die größte
niederlage auch des russischen volkes
war der zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
und das was wir jetzt in diesen stunden
erleben hat er angekündigt auch sein
generalstabschef general major gerasimov
hat es in einer rede vor der russischen
militärakademie die veröffentlicht
worden ist bereits vor einigen jahren so
gesagt also es kommt für alle diejenigen
die russland genau beobachten und die
ist richtig analysiert haben nicht
überraschend es hat eine eskalation erst
eine rhetorische und dann eine
militärische eskalation in den letzten
jahren gegeben und dies ist der
vorläufige höhepunkt der wird sie haben
gesagt und ich glaube sie haben sich
selber dort nicht ausgenommen wenn ich
sie richtig verstanden habe man sei nun
auf dem harten boden der realität
aufgeschlagen heißt jetzt kalkulieren
sie kalkulieren wir mit einem dass putin
einfach knallhart lügt einer seiner
letzten aussagen war man wolle ja nicht
die gesamte ukraine es ging nur um die
sogenannten volksrepublik die
selbstverständlich auch startgebiete
ukraine sind
wie ernst können wir das dann noch
nehmen glauben sie dass nun die gesamte
ukraine besetzt würde ich da vielleicht
noch erwähnen ich wir sind heute schon
sehr früh live gegangen bei bild live
und wir haben dann die stadt lemberg wo
mein kollege philipp petrow ist heute
morgen an moderiert mit der aussage dies
sei wohl die stadt in der die
flüchtlingswellen aufschlagen werden das
sei aber verhältnismäßig sicher der
werde vermutlich nichts passieren eine
stunde später
schalteten wir wieder zu unseren
korrespondenten und im hintergrund waren
die sirenen zu hören und erst der
einschläge offenbar auch in der nähe
dieser stadt soll heißen die
informationen über holen sich die ganze
zeit und putin geht möglicherweise doch
sehr viel weiter was glauben sie wie
weitergehen zunächst einmal muss man
wissen wie putin herkommt putin ist ein
mann der geheimdienstes ein mann des fsb
des großen russischen
auslandsgeheimdienstes für den er in
dresden
jahre lang tätig war und er ist immer
ein mann der geheimdienste geblieben er
hat sich auch mit
repräsentanten der geheimdienste engem
geben das ist seine welt in der er lebt
er und er ist ein perfekter agitator
eines propaganda systems die russische
propaganda hat sich immer auch gegen den
westen immer auch gegen die nato
gerichtet hat sich immer auch gegen alle
demokratiebewegungen gerichtet und
deswegen wird er jetzt sehr folgerichtig
und sehr stringent vorgehen er wird alle
strategischen punkte besetzen das heißt
luftraum das heißt rundfunk und
fernsehanstalten das heißt die zentralen
in den provinzen und in der hauptstadt
er wird nicht das ganze land besetzen
das dafür ist die ukraine zu groß aber
er wird alle strategischen punkte so
besetzen dass dieses land vollständig in
die russische einflusssphäre gerät und
er wird versuchen eine russland
freundliche regierung in kiew zu
installieren und das heißt im klartext
er wird mit diesem teil europas
versuchen das wieder herzustellen was er
immer bedauert hat was gescheitert ist
nämlich die alte sowjetunion sind sie
für waffenlieferungen auch von
deutschland an die ukraine der zeitpunkt
wenn er überhaupt jemals da war ist
verstrichen das problem dort lässt sich
jetzt nicht mehr mit waffen lösen die
russische armee nur um die zahl zu
nennen die russische armee hat eine
million aktive soldaten unter waffen es
ist völlig ausgeschlossen diesem
konflikt jetzt militärisch noch
abzuwenden oder zu gewinnen aber wir
müssen natürlich unterhalb der schwelle
der militärischen bewaffnung der
ukrainischen armee und der militärischen
lösung des konfliktes alles tun um
russland jetzt zu isolieren weltweit
auch zu isolieren und das
allerwichtigste wo ihr was jetzt
geschehen muss ist dass der westen diese
westliche staatengemeinschaft die
vereinigten staaten von amerika der
gesamte pazifische raum ich nenne
ausdrücklich japan australien viele
andere aber auch die europäer in ihren
reaktionen jetzt ganz eng beisammen
bleiben und ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
dass das gelingt märz diese antwort
verstehe ich nicht wirklich wir haben
einen aggressor und während sie gerade
gesprochen haben habe ich die
information live ins studio gekommen
dass russische bodentruppen nun wirklich
in die ukraine massiv einmarschieren sie
sagen gleichzeitig in der zeitpunkt für
waffengewalt ist jetzt vorbei ist
jetzt nicht genau der zeitpunkt für
waffengewalt und ich habe ja nun nicht
gefragt ob man die bundeswehr jetzt doch
den scheck das wäre sicher noch mal ein
ganz anderer schritt eine überlegung die
nicht zur debatte steht aber müssten wir
nicht waffen in die ukraine schicken
wohnen wirklich die leute
offenbar kämpfen werden und kämpfen
wollen um ja wo ihr wer ist wir sind das
die oma die hat meine frage ist hinter
sollte deutschland jedoch schlafen in
die ukraine die antwort ist klar und
deutlich nein auch der amerikanische
präsident hat ausgeschlossen dass
amerikanische truppen hier involviert
werden amerika liefert bereits seit
einigen monaten waffen an die
ukrainische armee ich hätte es auch in
deutschland befürwortet dass wir das mit
einer gruppe von europäischen staaten
vor einigen wochen schon hätten tun
sollen
das hätte auch die risikoschwelle für
putin deutlich erhöht wahrscheinlich
werden die historiker eines tages die
frage beantworten müssen ob es nicht
doch richtig gewesen wäre die ukraine in
die nato aufzunehmen
denn auch das hätte die risikoschwelle
für putin deutlich erhöht aber das ist
jetzt alles geschichte der entscheidende
punkt ist dass wir jetzt in der nato
zusammen stehen und dass wir putin vor
allen dingen aufzeigen dass nato
territorium für ihn wirklich die absolut
dunkel rote linie ist und das geht nur
wenn wir auch in den osteuropäischen
nato staaten das sind vor allen dingen
die baltischen staaten aber auch polen
und dem gesamten östlichen bereich der
nato hier starke präsenz zeigen und ihm
auch sehr deutlich machen dass
abschreckung wichtig ist und dass
abschreckung für uns jetzt das mittel
der wahl wenn sie nur über militärische
operationen oder optionen sprechen ich
muss hier noch einmal nachhaken der
klarheit wegen das heißt sie sind jetzt
nicht mehr vor waffenlieferungen wären
aber für waffenlieferungen vor kurzem
noch gewesen also was wäre wenn fragen
zu beantworten ist in dieser situation
äußerst schwierig noch einmal das wird
eines tages die rückschau ergeben ob das
richtig gewesen wäre oder nicht jetzt
sind wir in dieser situation und jetzt
müssen wir handeln und handeln heißt im
klartext wirklich alle möglichkeiten
unterhalb einer militärischen
intervention auszuschöpfen russland zu
isolieren auch auszuschließen vom
internationalen zahlungsverkehr von
banken verkehr auszuschließen von allen
technologischen transferleistungen die
dort geleistet werden dieses land muss
wirklich vollständig isoliert werden und
ich denke da sind die europäer da sind
auch die amerikaner auf dem richtigen
weg herr merz es gibt allerdings noch
andere player andere akteure dieser
krise wir haben heute morgen schon
erfahren das belarussische truppen die
russischen truppen
unterstützen dass das ist auch schon gar
kein konflikt mehr zwischen zwei staaten
sondern ein dritter staat wenngleich
auch ein marionetten staat moskaus ist
in den krieg eingetreten wie groß ist
die gefahr eines brandes in dieser
gesamten weltregion diese weltregion
brennt seit heute nacht ich sehe aber
noch eine andere große gefahren der
propagandakrieg begrenzt sich ja nicht
nur auf europa sondern die chinesische
staatsführung
tritt ein in diese propaganda russlands
das scheint eng abgestimmt zu sein und
wir müssen jetzt bei aller fokussierung
auf diesen konflikt
gleichzeitig sehr genau beobachten was
eigentlich in china passiert die
chinesische staatsführung schaut sich
dies sehr genau an und wird die frage
beantworten wie hoch die risikoschwelle
denn für sie ist etwa bei einem versuch
taiwan militärisch zu übernehmen und das
ist der nächste große krisenherd der
welt auf den wir schauen müssen und wir
müssen auch die chinesen station sehr
klar und so deutlich sagen dass wir
nicht akzeptieren werden dass eine
solche eskalation dort stattfindet ist
es aus ihrer sicht eine möglichkeit dass
sich der chinesische präsident sind in
und der russische präsident wladimir
putin abgesprochen haben im sinne ich
lasse dich in der ukraine machen und im
schatten dieses krieges können wir uns
ja teil variieren das ist offensichtlich
so putin war ja vor einigen tagen in
beijing und hat mit jinping gesprochen
ziemlich sicher auch abgestimmt mit ihm
was er dort vor hat er hat ja große
teile der russischen verbände auch aus
dem osten des landes aus dem osten
russlands abgezogen und jetzt in den
westteil verlegt er macht im grunde
genommen da diese flanke offen und hat
sie sich sicher politisch diplomatisch
abgesichert mit der chinesischen führung
und ich denke sie und ich sind uns einig
in der beurteilung dass dann auch
tatsächlich die möglichkeit eines
weltkriegs ich fühle mich sehr wohl
dieses wort auch nur auszusprechen man
möchte das gar nicht mal denken aber
durchaus im raum steht
ich zögere mit meiner antwort wie sie
sehen aber es ist in der tat richtig
dieser konflikt könnte sich ausweiten
aber gerade vor dieser frage vor diesem
hintergrund ist es jetzt wirklich
wichtig dass die nato das die
nato-mitgliedstaaten zeigen dass sie
bereit sind demokratie und freiheit dort
wo sie ist wo die nato ist zu
verteidigen und das ist eben auch unser
tal europas herr merz ihre partei hat 16
jahre lang hier die regierungschefin
gestellt und die regierung gestellt in
dieser zeit haben wir praktisch nie
unseren soll für die nato vollständig
erfüllt die bundeswehr ist einer
desolaten lage ich habe auch freunde in
der bundeswehr die mir berichten von
flugzeugen die nicht fliegen von
schiffen die nach drei minuten auf hoher
see zurück in den hafen kehren müssen
und obendrein hat ihre partei ja auch
die verhandlungen mit putin bis
vergangenes jahr geführt und hat da so
nun meine journalistische einschätzung
auch die gefahren nicht wirklich erkannt
und richtig eingeschätzt wie viel schuld
trifft hier die cdu und was hätten sie
auch in der rückschau als partei anders
machen müssen wir sind sicherlich alle
beteiligt an diesem zustand auch der
deutschen bundeswehr ich will allerdings
auch hinzufügen menschen in diesem land
die 40 jahre und jünger sind haben
allein aufgrund ihrer lebenserfahrung
überhaupt kein gefühl mehr für bedrohung
gehabt das wird wahrscheinlich in diesen
tagen jetzt anders und das gibt uns dann
auch die gelegenheit nochmal sehr
kritisch auch selbst kritisch zu
überprüfen welche fehler gemacht worden
sind in der verteidigungspolitik hinter
außenpolitik und das ist zunächst einmal
eine risikoeinschätzung eine zutreffende
risikoabwägung und da werden wir
sicherlich zu neuen ergebnissen kommen
müssen deutschland wird jetzt mit der
sehr harten realität einer sehr brutalen
welt da draußen konfrontiert und kann
sich auch dieser analyse auch diesem
risiko nicht mehr entziehen und muss
darauf angemessen reagieren ich gehe
davon aus dass wir darüber auch
politisch diskutieren müssen in
deutschland meine wahrnehmung ist dass
dies jetzt auch die amtierende koalition
aus spd fdp und grünen dabei ist zu
begreifen wir alle haben hier ein stück
verantwortung zu tragen nicht nur für
die vergangenheit sondern vor allem für
die zukunft märz wir haben über die
fehler ihrer eigenen partei gesprochen
wie beurteilen sie als oppositionsführer
die regierungsarbeit und vielleicht noch
mal einen besonderen fokus auch auf die
tatsache dass es in der spd nach wie vor
einen harten kern an menschen gibt die
putin nicht nur verständnis
entgegenbringen sondern die ihn sogar
unterstützen und das ist eben nicht nur
der sogenannte möchte ich fast sagen ex
kanzler schröder der heute zu tage
primären gas lobbyist ist sondern das
sind auch andere leute wie zum beispiel
manuela schwesig die vielleicht nicht
putin persönlich das verständnis
gegenüber bringen aber doch auch mit
tricksereien eine stiftung etabliert hat
und deren deckmantel nord stream zwei
weitergeführt wurde wie beurteilen sie
all das und wie beurteilen sie auch dann
die arbeit von olaf scholz und der
regierung in dieser krise olaf scholz
hat sich ja in moskau bei seinem besuch
klar und deutlich von seinem vor
vorgänger distanziert
ich gehe davon aus dass er das in
gleicher weise auch gegenüber denen tut
die nach wie vor verständnis für putin
und russland bis in die jüngsten tage
hinein geäußert haben ich kann von
meiner seite aus lossagen die
informationen die gespräche die wir die
ich auch persönlich mit der
bundesregierung führen sind sehr offen
sind auf zusammenarbeit ausgerichtet wir
werden diese zusammenarbeit mit der
bundesregierung auch in der praxis
umsetzen jedenfalls solange wir von der
gleichen risikoanalyse ausgehen und die
gleichen schlussfolgerungen daraus
ziehen ich kann nur hoffen dass
diejenigen die da in der spd unterwegs
waren das ist eine sehr große gruppe
jetzt durch die ereignisse der letzten
24 stunden endgültig von diesem naiven
bild putins abstand beste mann schröder
alle privilegien streichen
das verhalten von gerhard schröder ist
aus meiner sicht nicht nur inakzeptabel
es ist es ist peinlich es ist unangenehm
es ist unpassend aber sagen sie mal
konkret der sex kalimarkt geld müssten
wir sagen ich gehe bei audi hoffe dass
er jetzt mal von sich aus die
konsequenzen zieht sonst wird es
sicherlich im parlament eine rolle
spielen eine letzte frage von mir ich
habe gerade gehört vitali klitschko
prominenter ukrainischer
politiker sagte die lage sei nicht
komplett aussichtslos aber ich zitiere
wörtlich wir brauchen die unterstützung
der gesamten welt wir sprachen bereits
über waffenlieferungen
das bleibt dann etwas indifferent das
thema wenn ich das so sagen darf sie
sprachen nun von sanktionen gegenüber
russland die menschen in der ukraine
vitali klitschko selbst hoffen auf
anderes die hoffen wirklich dass jetzt
deutsche waffen dort ankommen
französische waffen dort ankommen dass
wir truppen an den grenzen an die nato
grenzen zumindest gegenüber russland
verstärken wie klar können wir da
jenseits
von den fast möchte ich sagen üblichen
aussagen sanktionen und so weiter jetzt
werden also das sind nicht übliche
aussagen die ich hier mache sondern sehr
wohl überlegt auch abgestimmt zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt herbei und das will
ich noch mal unterstreichen ist es für
eine solche aufrüstung der ukraine zu
spät wenn dann hätte man das früher
machen müssen die risikoschwelle für
putin war zu niedrig erkennbar wir
werden jetzt gegenüber der übermacht der
russischen armee und noch einmal die die
russische armee verfügt über eine
million soldaten davon sind mindestens
200.000 jetzt im einsatz wir werden
diesen konflikt in der ukraine
militärisch nicht mehr lösen können das
was wir tun können ist eine genügend
hohe abschreckung auf dem nato
territorium sicherzustellen und das
betrifft insbesondere die
osteuropäischen nato staaten ganz
besonders die baltischen staaten und
hier jetzt auch militärische präsenz zu
zeigen und zu erhöhen ist richtig
notwendig vielleicht sogar überfällig
heißt im grunde herr merz dass sie die
ukraine als eigenständigen souveränen
staat verloren geben noch einmal
militärisch ist diese operation jetzt
hier nicht mehr zu gewinnen aber wir
geben sie natürlich nicht verloren es
gibt immer noch die hoffnung dass wir
auch putin und sein gesamtes system so
weit jedenfalls neutralisieren können
dass es eines tages eine gute und
diplomatische eine friedliche lösung für
dieses land gibt und wir müssen jetzt
einfach abwarten was in den nächsten
stunden in den nächsten tagen geschieht
aber hier an der entschlossenheit des
westens keine zweifel entstehen zu
lassen ist das gebot der stunde und zwar
mit aller härte auch der sanktionen auch
der entsprechenden wirtschaftlichen
konsequenzen für russland sie müssen
einfach sehen
putin reagiert ja nicht aus einer
position der stärke das einzige was er
hat das militär den ganzen rest hat er
nicht das land ist wirtschaftlich
schwach es liegt am boden das land ist
zerrissen auch zwischen denen die
demokratie wollen und die dieses system
unterstützen putin die rede am
montagabend von putin war ja keine
souveräne rede eines starken politischen
führers sondern es war eine von angst
getriebene rede um seine eigene position
um die position seines umfeldes um
letztendlich auch das gesamte russische
nomenklatura system und insofern habe
ich die hoffnung dass es immer noch eine
lösung gibt allerdings nicht kurzfristig
herr merz das ist eine klare analyse von
ihnen nicht erlauben sie mir ihnen da
aber doch noch einmal zu widersprechen
ich habe die rede ganz anders empfunden
angst hatte in dem raum dann vor allem
schwerte der geheimdienstchef der
gezittert hat als er mit putin
gesprochen hat und sich mehrfach
korrigiert hat angst haben die
bürgerinnen und bürger in der ukraine
die jetzt mit waffengewalt
konfrontiert sind erste menschen sterben
bereits bodentruppen gehen in die
ukraine rein und sie haben mir selber
gesagt ja wahrscheinlich gab es eine
eine abstimmung zwischen moskau und
peking wo sich möglicherweise zwei
schurken ganz gut verstanden haben ist
es wirklich so dass putin aus einer
position der schwäche heraus agiert sein
eigenes volk ihn doch weitgehend egal
bzw
er konnte ja auch viel unterstützung
weil es ja oft das volk geben auch ein
das ist ein altbekannter zynischer trick
das volk hinter einer militärischen
expansion zu 1 also nochmal meine frage
ist das wirklich eine position der
schwäche am ende wirken wir der westen
doch heute viel schwächer der ist
nämlich einfach geschehen lassen meine
analyse ist etwas differenzierter
militärisch ist sicherlich putin im
augenblick in der übermacht aber er ist
politisch geschwächt das land ist
wirtschaftlich sehr schwach er hat
widerstand im eigenen land die mehrheit
der russischen bevölkerung unterstützt
diesen waffengang erkennbar nicht das
werden wir auch in den nächsten tagen
sicherlich noch mal sehr viel deutlicher
sehen und wir sind umgekehrt
demokratisch gestärkt der westen rückt
zusammen ist übrigens meine beobachtung
auch vom vergangenen wochenende auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz ich bin
dort seit über 20 jahren ich habe selten
ich würde sagen noch nie eine solche
entschlossenheit des westens erlebt hier
zusammenzustehen und auch dieser
bedrohung gemeinsam zu begegnen nur mit
dem militärisch russland hat bereits
atomwaffenfähige waffensysteme in der im
land belarus stationiert es handelt sich
hier um ein krieg eines landes das über
ein sehr großes arsenal an atomwaffen
verfügt das macht keinen sinn jetzt die
militärische eskalation hier zu suchen
die geht allein von putin aus die nato
ist ein verteidigungsbündnis ihres
territoriums dazu gehört die ukraine
nicht nochmal wir werden eines tages
darüber intensiv reden müssen ob es
vielleicht doch ein fehler war sie 2008
nicht in die nato aufzunehmen aber das
ist jetzt teil der geschichte jetzt geht
es darum diesen teil europas vor
weiteren militärischen angriffen zu
schützen das werden wir leisten können
und den teil europas der gerade
betroffen ist von dieser militärischen
intervention eines tages in die
staatengemeinschaft der demokratie und
der freiheit zurück zu gewinnen herr
merz vielen dank dass sie heute bei uns
waren zu früh am morgen an diesen
bedauerlichen tag ich gebe zurück ins
studio zu meinem kollegen thomas kausch